ya ni infantino ha criticado la
hipocresía de occidente ante las
críticas acatar Qué valor tienen sus
palabras teniendo en cuenta el país en
el que se hace este mundial donde han
muerto según algunos reportes miles de
trabajadores y es conocido por la falta
de respeto a los Derechos Humanos
Buenas tardes Rodrigo verdaderamente
lamentables las declaraciones de gianni
infantino que se ubican un poco el
problema de las violaciones a derechos
humanos y creemos nosotras que además
no asuma la responsabilidad de la FIFA
al haber decidido realizar su torneo
insignia en un país abiertamente
violador de derechos humanos y que
además ha violado los derechos humanos
de personas migrantes vinculadas a la
construcción de las instalaciones para
este torneo mundial nos parece poco
responsable de parte de la FIFA en su
conjunto Y por supuesto del señor Jenny
infantil
y en concreto qué supone el gesto
Aparentemente intencionalmente empático
de infantino al decir que se siente
africano homosexual o trabajador
migrante
Bueno desde nuestro punto de vista como
amnistía internacional y quisiéramos
señalar que para sentirse empático
habría que asumir verdaderamente la
responsabilidad y haber exigido acatar
en la responsabilidad de la FIFA de
haber exigido al gobierno de Qatar que
se respetaran los Derechos Humanos de
las personas durante por supuesto todo
el torneo pero también durante la
construcción y no basta con sentirse
empáticos a nivel individual sino con
garantizar y exigir que el gobierno
garantice los derechos humanos de todas
las personas al hilo de esto que nos
está comentando infantino asegura que
gracias a la FIFA Qatar ha hecho avances
en por ejemplo su legislación laboral es
esto cierto o qué reportes tienen
ustedes como amnistía internacional
si nosotras más bien tenemos los
reportes que tenemos en el resto del
mundo de las violaciones a derechos
humanos que se han cometido durante la
construcción durante todo este proceso y
las que se han seguido cometiendo tanto
hacia las personas que viven en Qatar
como quienes van a visitar y creemos que
el compromiso de la FIFA debería
expresarse ahora también en un retorno
de la inversión y de las ganancias que
va a obtener la Fifa en esta copa del
mundo para que se inviertan en la
vigencia y respeto de los Derechos
Humanos especialmente de las personas
migrantes en Qatar pero de todas las
personas a las que se les violan
cotidianamente los Derechos Humanos la
posición de la FIFA Debería ser mucho
más fuerte para garantizar la vigencia
de los Derechos Humanos en los países en
donde se realizan estos torneos